it's the moment their families have been
waiting for hamas's release of two
elderly women held captive for more than
two weeks their husbands though remain
behind in Gaza where Israeli air strikes
is killing dozens of people every
day we're very emotional and happy that
my grandmother yab livitz and nured
Cooper both from the kibuts near o is
coming back to us in a real humanitarian
move we're expecting the rest to be
released all hostages from the kibuts
all hostages in
general Hamas maintains its treating its
civilian captives like guests and is
willing to release them without
conditions but says Israel hasn't
accepted we have declared on Friday that
we were ready to
release and another two Israelis women
at that time the Americans accepted to
have the two uh those two women back but
the Israelis rejected that prime
minister n rejected that Israel's prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu though
rejected this claim by saying the Army
and security forces have been active for
days in getting the captives released
earlier this week he said there would be
no negotiations with Hamas katar Egypt
and the US have been working together as
mediators behind the scenes and then
shortly after the grandmothers entered
Egypt through the Raa Crossing from Gaza
intense Israeli air strikes
resumed the heavy bombing of Gaza from
the air hasn't stopped since October 7
in Promises of a ground Invasion that
hasn't materialized yet has left many
Israelis searching for answers from
their government and questioning whether
the 210 captives will ever make it out
of Gaza
alive the arrival of the grandmothers in
Israel is likely to give desperate
families hope to be reunited again with
their loved ones and in Gaza people hope
for a rest fite from what is the worst
bombing they have ever
seen sarak Al jazer occupied East
Jerusalem